[Music]
ricardo is in
charlotte north carolina hey ricardo how
are you
hey dave how are you great man what's up
all right yes so right now i'm currently
21 year old
i have 35 000 saved in my bank account
um i'm currently in college
but um i'm i'm doing like debt free
because i'm getting some
help um and then i'm currently living
with my parents i've been thinking about
moving out
but i realize when i move out i'm
basically going to be like
living paycheck to paycheck so what do
you think i should do
when will you graduate from college um
next year
okay well it's not unusual for someone
to live at home until they graduate from
college
but if you're 28 you make 60 000 a year
in your in your mother's basement
there's issues dude
oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry i know you're
not you're 21 you live at home you don't
make any money you're going to college
you got 35 000 savings i got it
that's not you my point is you're what
you're doing is
a fairly normal process and it's not
does not indicate that you're
emotionally stunted
yeah yes um ricardo you're overthinking
this
you're in great shape you got a year
left i'd absolutely stay if it were me
saving money is there a relational
problem at home
um there is kind of a little bit i
actually do work full-time as well
um i make 14 an hour and um i'm
actually doing like this you know um on
like the regular shifts and everything
um but there is a little bit of problems
but i think we're finding a solution to
it
so yeah what are you studying um i'm
doing business administration
good for you and where did you get
where'd you get the 35 000
the what's right where did you get the
35 000
i've worked at several jobs during
couple years now
and that's how i said i'm pretty i'm
pretty good with budgeting i'm pretty
good with numbers
i love budgeting and doing all these
things
i don't think you're living paycheck to
paycheck i think you you've
misunderstood that phrase because you're
actually so conservative and so
disciplined you've got 35
000 dollars uh in the bank and you're
working full-time
and going to college debt-free i think
you just gave us it out there
he would be that's what he said yeah
because he'd be using up all of his
fourteen dollars just to pay
just to pay rent so uh who paid for
college
um so it was um i like my car my
family's coming from a low income so
i'm using my i'm help i got help from
fafsa which is
um it's like you don't have to pay it
back it's like government assistance
so you got pell grants yes pell grant
yes okay
all right because that's the only one
you don't pay back the rest of them
fafsa signed you up for makes you think
it was a
grand and it turns out it was a student
loan so um
yeah but okay now if you unless you have
a toxic
i mean a really nasty bad situation that
you've got to get out of there
i'm going to suck up whatever the
relationship thing is be humble
and finish my time there get out of
school graduate with 35 000
in the bank and a degree in business and
go get the big boy job
and uh move out then so that means
you're only there one more year
um yeah that's what i would recommend
and if you were my kid that's what i
would
ask you to do to continue to do that
but as you said it sounds like there's
some rough spots you guys need to smooth
out in the
rules of the house and when you live in
someone else's
house you live by their rules yeah and
also he's a number cruncher where i was
going is
you know could you get a roommate let's
see what what that looks like what does
your paycheck
allow you to do and could you get a
roommate and maybe still do it if not
as you're pointing out he's got a year
he's going to save up even more than the
35 thousand
living at home so he's going to be in
fantastic shape yeah you'll be able to
move out pretty easy with a
good solid job and and with the graduate
you know the new job after graduation
that
should be considerably more than 14 an
hour should put you in that position
so yeah it's um this is an interesting
age group
yeah we're talking to them you and i
both on the ken coleman show on sirius
xm and
but youtube is drawing in this 19 18 19
20 21 22 year old bunch and you know
used to that if we had someone call
and they said they were living at home
they were 28. oh yeah and so we
immediately jumped ahead and said
yeah come on you know but in this case
but we're having a lot of young people
who are go-getters
that uh i mean i'm talking to
19-year-olds with substantial
dollars that are calling in here and
they're doing these substantial things
so
a portion of that generation whatever
the label is that's on this
uh 18 to 24 year old generation whatever
that's not millennials certainly but
i don't i don't know the proper
demographic gen z or mosaics is what
they call them
z was before millennials wouldn't no
it's after is it i promise okay well you
probably know more than i do
you do it's what oh you mean oh no no
yeah x was x is me i'm j x well i know
that but and so then it's more
between um gen z i thought it was
mosaics i thought it was xz millennial
but
i what do i know obviously i don't know
so here bottom line is
this age group there is a
very serious group of them yes i don't
know if there's a bunch of dead beats in
there too i don't talk to them
but they're watching the ramsey show on
you youtube and are calling in
and that guy right there when i was 21
oh yeah
and 35 000 not even close i don't even
know how to say 35 000. you know and one
thing i want to point out
right now ricardo he's still listening
in ricardo i would challenge you to look
for
a job that pays more than 14 an hour
over the next year or so
because right now we're seeing companies
not the federal minimum wage but
companies are raising minimum wages
because there is
right now uh so many jobs that are open
and people aren't returning
now is the time in a metropolitan area
like charlotte north carolina ricardo as
sharp as you are
i would at least challenge you to look
to not maybe you could find something in
the 17
18 20 an hour you'd be surprised what
companies are offering to try to get
talent
just stable talent in the door well they
might want to move you in there
into a business type job with your
business degree
yes sir it's almost like a paid
internship because they know you're one
year away from diploma
so i'd encourage him to do that as well
and then to what you were saying dave we
know this from the data there's recent
studies out
that this generation this gen z they're
they're in high school now they're in
their early 20s
more than any generation previous in
america
they are more entrepreneurial they are
thinking when they come out of high
school
that they're going to eventually own
their own business some want to go right
into it not even in the college
and those that are going into college
are thinking i'm going to college
because i want to work for me one day
we're seeing that big time and i think
we're seeing that reflected in
in the kids that are watching our show
well that's going to change the
political landscape
yes it will wait till they start seeing
the taxes come out yeah
yeah well not among other things yeah
yeah and all the other policies
trying to run a business with the
government breathing down your neck yeah
but the uh it's a very good point that's
a very good point
wow interesting labor market right now
yeah very cool
very cool ken coleman ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show on siriusxm
an ever popular podcast and of course 75
radio stations plus
carrying it now you can tune in and hear
him anytime he's my co-host today
this is the ramsey show